i'm not exaggerating
this baby is talking
yo you talking
and you just turned four months today
you talking for real
cardi b and offsets baby boy may only be
four months old it's a blessing for god
but the rapper says he's already talking
oh snappity snap snap on wednesday the
29 year old grammy winner opened up
about the milestone moment on her insta
story and needless to say
she's shook i'm not exaggerating
this baby is talking
i i put this on everything i love in the
name of jesus christ like first of all
my husband saw it
um
yesterday i was like you love mommy yeah
come again you love mommy and he replied
back like yeah like not even like
it was like yeah
but cardian offsets baby boy whose name
they have yet to reveal isn't a one-hit
wonder oh yes honey
according to cardi he did it again and
then just now like he's watching coco
melon and they're like hey be happy to
say hello hello if you're happy you know
i say hello and then like when they stop
he said oh
yo this is crazy
i don't know if that's like the pandemic
thing i don't know if like this is
normal
yo like
this is crazy
like
i need a i need a camera in this room 24
7 or something because
yo you talking
and you just turned four months today
you talking for real
cardi and offset welcomed their little
bundle of joy to the world on september
4th at the time the love birds who also
share a three-year-old daughter culture
is she so cute i love her told et quote
we are so overjoyed to finally meet our
son he is already loved so much by
family and friends and we can't wait to
introduce him to his other siblings and
baby boy he just might be a baby genius
back in december cardi shared another
milestone on twitter revealing that at
just three months old he was already
mastering the art of eating quote my son
holding his bottle with both his hands
already i'm trying to remember if kk was
doing that around three months old or if
this is one of those superpowers these
pandemic babies coming with and while
the couple has kept their little one's
face off social media the i like it
rapper did give fans a glimpse at her
baby boy in a 30th birthday shout out
post dedicated to her husband i already
fell in love uh the way that he was a
dad already he's really good and don't
blink or you'll miss their newborn in
this insta post from december showing
off their over-the-top christmas decor
as for cardi she appears to be savoring
the newborn phase i love everything
about motherhood on tuesday she walked
fans through her morning routine with
her little guy which includes early
morning feedings and this relatable
moment
literally in my last pope i just say i'm
waiting on my morning poop i know this
baby too well
the morning poop already came
back in 2018 shortly after culture was
born cardi opened up to e.t about loving
every moment of mommyhood i like
everything like it's just a different
feeling it's just like it's a new
experience for me because it's like i'm
up all night i'm sucking her boogers i'm
making sure that she's breathing that's
a lot but i love everything